what up phoenix how we doing
I am glad you are here please sit I am
glad you're here I love you back bro
[Music]
thank you so much let's uh let's get
into it so look I think the thing that
inspires me this morning as we are now
clearly into late 2018
obviously we ate a bunch of turkey the
other day the holidays are upon us with
you know everyone's gonna get into that
mindset and very quickly it's going to
be 2019 by the way it's cold as [ __ ] in
here
Jesus people like in blankets and [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jesus and I was born in the Soviet
Union's that [ __ ] feels good but man
it's cold anyway here's the important
thing and I think whether you're 18 or
81 wherever you are in your career
you're pumped you're doing financially
well but you're not happy you're happy
but you're not financially where you're
at we're look when I look at this many
people the thing that runs through my
mind is what is the common denominator
in this room that over 30 minutes or so
I can bring value to the most amount of
people in this room and it comes down to
timing to me on the cusp of 2019 the
biggest thing that's running through my
mind very simply that matters to every
single person in this room is this
device this is a big deal and what it is
is it's a representation of something
even bigger which is this internet thing
is bigger than people realize and what's
happening in our culture right now
because of the political climate and
many other factors is I think the
majority of people in this room and a
majority people in this country and a
majority people in this world are
looking at the downside and the
negativities and the cynicism around the
internet without realizing social media
isn't changing us social media is
exposing who we actually are more
importantly it gets to the bigger
punchline which is if this is 1948 or
1978 or 1998 and not 2018 we would not
have the ridiculous opportunity that
this brings to the table
for me the one thing I know whether
you're a real estate investor a
politician you sell underwear you want
to be a personal brand you have a cocoa
drink you want to sell [ __ ] wooden
frames I know you sell wooden frames
I know that regardless of what you do
here b2b b2c whether you have 13 year
old customers are trying to sell things
to like slime or 88 year olds that
you're trying to force into your
retirement home versus somebody else's
that whether it's Facebook or Instagram
or YouTube or LinkedIn email text
messaging pre-roll YouTube ads Instagram
stories influencer marketing that the
great underpriced
the great underpriced opportunity in our
society is within seven to fifteen
platforms that are apps on the mobile
device the biggest thing that I'm
fascinated by is the amount of people in
this room's ability to say not my
customer not my industry not my demo
without recognizing how unbelievably
underpriced the attention is and when I
say underpriced attention I stand here
today for a very for many different
reasons mainly on the back of very good
parenting and circumstance of not being
born here but no question my timing of
joining my dad's liquor store coinciding
with email and Google AdWords being
underpriced attention is a reason that
I'm so passionate this morning in
Phoenix to get people to wake up and
actually go all-in on the things that
you've heard how many people here have
consumed my content somewhat raise your
hands thank you for that group I'm
actually way more concerned for that
group than the people in here that
aren't here for me and have never heard
any of this because for the group that
has consumed my content my concern is
that the repetitive nature of me trying
to desperately at all cost without
interest in monetizing you to go into
these channels and get yours that you
don't realize how real it is that it's
become passive noise yeah I get at
Facebook ads work yeah I get it
you know work hard to be packed like I
get it but the reality is here's what's
upsetting me the thing that I've been
the Pied Piper for for the last half
decade is starting to slip a little bit
like Facebook isn't as easy as it was 24
months ago and and by the way I just
said that sentence and hundreds of faces
just shook their head which means they
felt the effects of Facebook ads 24 or
36 months ago and they're starting to
realize they're not converting as well
or it's costing more to get the same or
the organic reach I think all of us know
the organic reach collapse 3-4 years ago
and how many people here are marketing
or actively using Instagram raise your
hand so for all those hands that are up
I'm sure you're starting to pay
attention at even over the last three or
four weeks it feels like something's
starting to happen because the organic
reach is starting to soften just enough
that it's getting on people's radars
which reminds me a whole lot of what
started happening when Google AdWords
prices went up when my email list
started looking at 70% open rates
instead of 80 and then on to 60 and then
to 50 and then to 40 my friends we're
sitting right now at this time in the
white heat moment of social networks
controlling a stunning majority of
people's attention and it's going to go
away and then there'll be another thing
for you to sit here and not take
advantage of the current state of the
internet when it's in your face if
you're here this morning this is is it
Wednesday is anyone say you know like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here on a
Wednesday morning I assume it would make
a lot of sense for me if you're sitting
in this audience I assume you came here
and spent your time and money to extract
value to do something that you want to
happen in your life right and there's
only two ways that gets done
there's the mental part and then there's
the tactical part it's real simple most
people play in the middle when the
reality is is if you're not all the way
over here and if you are not blindly and
this is what an entrepreneur or an
operator needs to be if you are not
right here this morning and you were
blindly optimistic about the
opportunities in front of you you are
vulnerable and do not mix
the word optimism with delusion I didn't
say if you're blindly delusional if
you're delusional
you're [ __ ] but if you're cynical or
pessimistic or if you're gonna listen to
me when I go all the way over here
because that's the mindset or if you're
over here and you're like me and others
and you're also a hundred percent
practical and you understand how to
actually execute and you actually do the
work if you're not in those two places
you're vulnerable and you came here this
morning only to check the box on one of
the two things and to me the thing on
the left I have to be contextual I know
that Tony's gonna speak I know that
Roberts is me I listen I'm thrilled to
talk to you about why optimism and
mindset and positivity and all that
stuff is a hundred percent it just is if
you've decided when you woke up that
Facebook Ads don't work they don't work
so for me that's cool but honestly in
the limited time that I have with you I
want to go practical with you which is
like Instagram story ads you can google
it I don't need a [ __ ] chart there
doesn't need to be a deck I'm not gonna
draw some [ __ ] pictures on a
whiteboard it's called Google you have
it in your [ __ ] hand right now so if
you don't know what I'm about to say
mentally remind yourself and if you're
not good at that take a note right now
on your iPad or your phone you should be
running Instagram story ads for your
business why because they're grossly
underpriced why because hundreds of
millions of people look through them
every single day and are paying
attention and more people are not buying
it yet
because they don't know how good it is
it's called supply and demand your job
is not to just buy them you have to
figure out what picture and video to put
in front of their that compels the
person to do whatever the hell you want
vote for you for the PTA president or
give you seven hundred thirty bucks for
your magical [ __ ] berries
I kind of want to leave now I kind of do
I'll tell you why in like it was funny
why that just happened to me my buddy
Mike like that's it
like life is so simple whoever was best
at radio content and advertising grew in
the 30s and 40s whoever was best at
television commercials and TV shows in
the 50 60 70 80s 90s 2000s they grew and
they won whoever is best at Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn Twitter today
is winning that was a shitty ass clap
and let and let me tell you and let me
tell you why it's a shitty ass clap
because to be great at the things that
just came out of my mouth is hard
it sounds great that you're gonna start
an Instagram account and take a picture
of you taking a [ __ ] hike and your
business is gonna explode the problem is
that's not what happens is it there's a
lot of people here how many people here
want to be an influencer or a personal
brand in their industry raise your hands
raise it high so here's what bugs the
[ __ ] out of me
13250 percent of the hands in this room
just went up the amount of people who
just posted something on Instagram
yesterday had nine people comment but
they didn't reply to them because
they're more worried about how many
likes they're gonna get or how many
followers they get from the post not the
actual nine people that give a [ __ ]
about them is why 99% of you will never
achieve it it's true
and I appreciate you for clapping first
sir with the glasses I saw you and for
me for me that's the most important part
and that for the same reason I saw that
gentleman who actually started the whole
clap in this room
it's the reason I stand up here today I
spend my life reading your comments on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and email
that's how I have the insights to create
the next thing cuz you're giving me the
feedback of what's working and not
working for you the audacity of
businesses and people in 2019 in putting
out content but then disrespecting their
audience because the only thing they
care about is well their audience give
them what they want
likes follows money is the reason it's
so hard my friends if you leave Phoenix
today with anything when you go home
understand this if you are not producing
content for the internet you are leaving
an incredible opportunity on the table
and your competitors have started the
process to hurt you now producing
content on the Internet is extremely
interesting because so many people look
at certain people and decide that's the
only way many people are dominating
content and internet without ever
producing one video in their lives
because they're tremendous writers
others are self-conscious to put a
camera in front of them but they're
great with their voice so they're
killing it in podcast form if you leave
with anything please don't be like me in
the way that I produce content be like
me in the way that I deploy
self-awareness of what I'm good at and
then triple down on it to produce it you
might be great at drawing communicate
like that you might be great at just
random thoughts and recording it on memo
on your phone and you can post that you
might be great on camera
and honestly much like movies and
television if you are great on video
it's good it carries weight but please
leave here and look yourself in the
rearview mirror or when you get home and
ask yourself how do I communicate and
start communicating the
the trick the unlock the place that you
will hear an enormous amount of
pontificating for me in 2019 will be
around the volume of content that you
produce for the 10 platforms over the
last year what has become unbelievably
obvious to me that works for me
thousands of other people and the brands
that are winning in society the
businesses that are growing the one
correlation that's just black and white
to me is volume of creative how many
times do they post quality content how
much influence or marketing how many
articles white papers podcasts videos
way the world is working with Internet
content there is so much content you
could never over saturate the market
even if you made 90 pieces of content a
day about yourself but this is why I
went over here as I'm talking the
interesting part of why most of you are
not producing enough content has a hell
of a lot more to do with this than with
this we are crippled by other people's
opinions you're not posting because you
want [ __ ] to be perfect why do you want
it to be perfect because you're [ __ ]
insecure you know why because it just
ruins your day when fat pants 86 leaves
a comment and says that you're stupid
right you're just super sad when you
post something and you're used to
getting 89 likes but this one got 62 I
have become outrageously fascinated by
something over the last two years which
is oh my god the majority of people live
their lives based on other people's
opinions whether it's their parents
older sibling or even worse the current
state the anonymous person
their YouTube comments that sucks and so
over the last two years especially the
last year I'm trying to figure out what
is this and how do I speak about this in
a world where I know the majority of the
reasons you came here today can be
solved by your ability to produce
content on seven web sites for real for
real why were people not doing it that
blindly believed that to be true it
became about judgment it became about
mindset and that's what I'm trying to
tackle and that's what I'm trying to
give to you this morning I'm trying to
figure out like who what it's why I talk
so much about patience I used to think
it was patience and it is because every
22-year old wants it tomorrow everybody
every 40 year old wants it tomorrow we
just lack patience because unfortunately
so many people here and I mean this and
this is not tough love or as it's just
the truth so many people here went into
cryptocurrency or cannabis or social
media because they thought they were
gonna make the money faster
people lose cuz they think it's gonna
happen fast when life is long and so
I've been spending a lot of time on this
just watching behaviors who's winning
who's winning is the person that likes
what they do it's true like how many
more [ __ ] millionaires do I have to
hang out with that are gonna take their
life or in deep depression or doing
drugs and alcohol to deal with the pain
cuz making 2.3 million dollars a year
brings them zero [ __ ] happiness and
how many people do I have to hang out
with that make 87,000 a year that sells
Smurf t-shirts on the internet and love
[ __ ] life you like that one it's good
you're gonna sell some smart t-shirts
go without open market shit's gettin
very clear for me maybe it's because I'm
getting older now but shit's gettin very
clear to me it's pattern recognition
life is very basic we make it
unbelievably complicated
we're unbelievably products of the DNA
and the parents and the environment we
grew up on and we have to really
understand that so we know how to
navigate the next step people lack the
ability to put their life in perspective
I've been pushing people lately who are
43 year old entrepreneurs sending me
emails and they have a six year old
child they love their business they're
killing it things are going great and my
advice to men is to slow down and take
the next 12 years and actually because
they're telling me what they know about
themselves is if they go to little Ricky
and little Janet's softball games and
recitals and if they hang out with them
and play Wii with them all day that
that's what's gonna make them happy and
then they think they're sending me an
email because I'm business guy and I'm
gonna tell them that's wrong are you out
of your [ __ ] mind you need to be
happy and if you're self-aware enough to
know that at 43 years old
you've six-year-old kids that you want
to spend the next 12 years taking the
foot off the pedal so you can allocate
time to watch those kids grow I've got
tremendous news for you you're just
gonna be 55 and the baby when they go to
college and they're not gonna want to
talk to you anyway and you gonna be able
to go all in
[Music]
you know how liberating it is when
people understand how young 59 years old
is do you know how many people think
they're supposed to have their life
figured out at 18 22 and 30 when the
parents that are putting pressure on
them to figure out their lives don't
have their lives figured out oh I like
that one how the [ __ ] are you supposed
to have your whole life figured out at
28 years old it's ludicrous
we have such interesting macro theses in
our society that are crippling people
and the reason there's so much anxiety
in the system now is we're all living
our lives in public forums and now
taking on more judgment not less I don't
hear any of you let me say it one more
time how many people here [ __ ] with my
content and they love it let me hear you
can't hear you can't hear you
let me say it one more time for all the
people here who think I [ __ ] walk on
water I'm the best I'm such a great dude
I can't [ __ ] hear you let me explain
why not you bro
let me explain to you why I can't hear
you because I have no interest on
getting high on my own supply
the reason the reason I can't hear you
is the same reason that I can't hear the
person that leaves a comment that says
I'm a snake oil salesman or my cursing
is inappropriate or I suck or I'm gonna
burn out or whatever else I can't hear
that [ __ ] face either and when over the
next 50 years of my life I figure out
how to produce more communications to
help you not hear it either that is when
I will start having more significant
income impact because when you don't
hear anything and I don't mean from just
fatty pants 63 I mean from your dad I
mean from your spouse when you my
friends in Phoenix on a Wednesday going
into 2019 when you stop hearing things
[ __ ] gets remarkable
how many people here have been following
me for more than four years raise your
hands raise it high please so for the
ones that raised their hands you know
something about me you know that I'm not
interested in being a motivational
speaker you know that four years ago I
was making much more tactical jab jab
jab right hook like I didn't want to
rah-rah what I just did for the last ten
minutes I don't want to be that guy I
have it in me I live it I believe it but
I don't want to go on stage and rah-rah
and have collapse I don't I don't
the reason I'm back here is what I want
is for you to post nineteen pieces of
content tomorrow on LinkedIn Facebook
YouTube and Instagram because they will
answer the [ __ ] things that are
running through your head right now the
problem was after I was done doing that
for three or four years and you would
look me dead in the face in a meeting
let alone in a stage and be like I get
it I understand it but you still weren't
doing it I'm like I don't get it and
then I got it this is such a big deal
like you're literally literally not
posting [ __ ] or more interestingly you
are posting [ __ ] because you are now all
the PR agents of yourselves on social
media it's really great to take a
beautiful family picture picking [ __ ]
pumpkins meanwhile shit's not going well
it's really awesome to post a picture on
a private plane saying you're killing it
when your company is about to go out of
business we are posturing my friends we
are posturing for other people's
opinions your lack of action is exposing
your insecurities if you're educated if
you follow me and you are not posting 10
to 15 pieces of content a day your
actions are exposing your insecurities
the end so I come on the stage this
morning with heat and passion because a
I'm [ __ ] well rested Thanksgiving was
a good rest for me but B I come here
because I'm just trying to [ __ ] get
one person in this room who's looking at
me right now and saying that's actually
the truth um I appreciate that I am I am
not posting because my hair is receding
and I'm insecure about it I'm being
serious
I'm being dead [ __ ] serious I am not
posting because I'm up 13 pounds and I
don't want to hear the [ __ ] comments
I'm not posting because all my high
school friends seem to be doing better
than me you're hearing too much you're
putting other people's opinions at a
higher place than your own happiness it
blows my face away and I kiss the ground
that my parents walk on for creating an
infrastructure that didn't create that
for me you know why and this is for all
the how many people here our parents of
six to 18 year olds raise your hands
this one's for you
let me tell you why it didn't happen to
me because from 6 to 18 the world told
me I was a loser because I played a
bunch of sports in the backyard and in
leagues and we didn't give a place
trophies when you [ __ ] lost
[Music]
you know why else I can't hear you
because I grew up in an environment
where every [ __ ] teacher looked me
dead in the face and told me I was gonna
be a loser cuz I got an F in science I
don't give a [ __ ] about Jupiter dick do
you know why I could post everyday and
not care about what you have to say
because every friend I hads parent in
high school when they asked me what
college I was going to when I said now I
to college they snickered in my [ __ ]
face losing is great I got lucky
I was born in a shitty [ __ ] place
called the Soviet Union
I got luckier by getting the [ __ ] out
and coming to America the greatest
[ __ ] country in the world and being
raised by a mother who would clap me up
just like that if I opened the door for
an old lady but when I asked her for a
Nintendo game she looked me dead in the
face and said go [ __ ] and figure it out
and buy it for yourself dick
you want to want know why most people
aren't winning and aren't happy it's cuz
you're [ __ ] entitled people think
they're owed something I know brother
people for some reason I watch it every
day nobody owes you [ __ ] figure it the
[ __ ] out and I'm gonna give you the two
basic principles they're so [ __ ]
simple it scares the [ __ ] at me number
one this you have to learn to do this
please my friends I've never done this
before it's weird I can't hear anything
please I didn't even hear you guys
laughing but I can see you doing it this
is really [ __ ] fun actually I might
give a whole keynote like this one is
[ __ ] freaking a [ __ ] I see you I've
seen clapping hands listen to me
clapping hands this this is the secret
to my happiness
I'm so [ __ ] happy cuz I can't hear a
[ __ ] thing do you understand when you
get there you start doing because you're
not scared that you hired somebody and
they didn't work out you just fire them
you don't care that your other
co-workers think that you made a mistake
you start doing and talking [ __ ] that
it's all gonna be great
because if it is awesome you're cool and
if it's not you don't care anyway
because as soon somebody brings it up do
you know why I had the audacity and make
a sneaker do you know why I did it
let me tell you why cuz I can't hear
anything if it worked and thank god it
did I look good if it didn't my seven
best friends would make fun of me for
the rest of my life and that was good
too I was looking forward to my roast at
83 when Robbie turn ik was like and
remember that time you thought you could
sell a sneaker
you're a real [ __ ] dick
learn to eliminate judgment learn to
realize the reason you're not posting
every day eight hundred times a day is
because you're worried about what people
are gonna say my friends high school is
over start acting like it
[Music]
because you're stuck in high school I'm
serious
it took me a long time it took me a long
time to figure out why this was working
for me I'm like right if I was able to
navigate high school and not fall into
peer pressure that's the hardest part
this is easy I just need you to create
content I need you to figure out how to
do it I could care less but all seven
thousand of you said to me of what
you're trying to do the answer is
content I'm being dead serious it's
where our world is living news alert
this is now real life this is fake you
don't like it tough [ __ ] technology
doesn't care about your feelings about
the old days leave it the Beavers
[ __ ] dead sorry Abraham Lincoln died
too in a weird way actually but the
point of that analogy is [ __ ] changes we
have to figure out this I don't care if
you're 18 or 81 I don't want to hear
that you didn't grow up with it you
didn't grow up driving you figured it
out you have something called Google and
YouTube Google if you like to read
YouTube if you're more visual you type
in every question you have how does a
lawyer make content on LinkedIn
thousands of results how does a
pharmacist grow her brand on Instagram
thousands of results it's also free it's
also free it's 2019 act like it
Phoenix thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]